how do we know that changes in carbon
dioxide are responsible for recent
climate change well what determines the
temperature of a planet the amount of
energy coming in from the Sun and the
amount of energy leaving the planet if
more energy comes in than leaves the
planet warms up the energy leaving is
modified by what we call greenhouse
gases the more of them there are in the
atmosphere the less energy leaves the
most important greenhouse gases are in
order water vapor carbon dioxide and
methane yes methane don't at me
Americans so we've observed warming why
has the amount of energy coming in from
the Sun increased no since 1880 it's
varied by less than a tenth of a percent
and it's actually decreased okay have we
seen an increase in greenhouse gases
like water vapor yes there has been an
observable increase in the amount of
water vapor in the atmosphere however
that's not coming from natural sources
like volcanic eruptions it's coming from
a 50 increase in the amount of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere and a 260
increase in the amount of methane both
caused by humans those increases
together decrease the amount of energy
leaving the planet and so causes warming
which causes more evaporation from the
world's oceans and so leads to more
water vapor in the atmosphere which then
causes more warming